okay have you guys seen any procedures  or policies put in place to put more  female leadership in place where you  work  [Music]  to think about it and I was like oh well  at my workplace I'm a senior waitress  which is like head waitress or wait  taught in in the front house of in front  of house there's other women that also  um have well there's another lady should  I say that is also a head waitress as  well but apart from that it smells and  just smells and there's any other one  female manager and I believe that she's  being combated by two other males so are  you even relevant we're not sure but um  I just feel like  women are given are being given more um  positions but I'll be being trusted with  the positions that we've been given  that's the problem imagine giving me a  job and you've um employed me knowing  that this is the um this is my  experience and then still somehow  questioning my experience it's like do  you not know what you employed me for